[Musique]
dans cette émission nous ouvrons les
portes de différents mondes et le monde
de notre invité c'est celui du scénario
de la réalisation c'est celui du cinéma
populaire et exigeant un cinéma qui
reste dans les mémoires de tous jeunes
moins jeunes qui traversent toutes les
générations ce qu'elle a écrit et
réalisée ce sont des films qu'on regarde
10 fois 100 fois en famille avec des
amis avec les copains des enfants quand
tout va bien ou quand on a pas le moral
des films qu'on finit par s'approprier
et qui intègre notre propre histoire la
Grande Vadrouille la folie des grandeurs
les aventures de Rabbi Jacob la boum 1
La Boum 2 l'étudiante la bûche fauteuil
d'orchestre des succès des films
essentiels qui ont su trouver une place
dans nos cinémathèques intimes mais
comment a-t-elle fait comment fait-on
pour sentir à ce point les attentes d'un
public d'une époque comment fait-on pour
écrire des dialogues et des histoires
dont les gens se souviendront toute leur
vie posons lui toutes ces questions
bienvenue dans un monde un regard
bienvenue à vous Daniel Thompson merci
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
ici au Sénat dans le dôme Tournon vous
êtes scénariste dialogiste réalisatrice
est-ce qu'il pourrait d'ailleurs vous
inspirer un scénario ce lieu où le Sénat
une comédie au Sénat vous qui aimait les
associations un peu insolites pourquoi
pas vous avez déjà pensé non mais tout
peut m'inspirer en effet ça fait partie
effectivement de du comment vous faites
puisque vous vous posiez la question je
crois que c'est la curiosité et le fait
d'être beaucoup à l'écoute de ce qui se
passe de la vie des gens de certains
décors qui peuvent aussi inspirer
quelque chose de choisir un lieu de
tournage et d'obtenir les autorisations
je crois que parfois c'est compliqué
notamment
c'est souvent très compliqué mon père
était très doué pour ça donc parce que
la plupart les filles les grands films
que vous avez cités sont quand même ces
films à lui plus plus qu'à qui que ce
soit et donc c'est vrai qu'il avait un
don particulier pour séduire ceux qui
pouvaient donner les autorisations
notamment d'ailleurs André Malraux qui
lui a donné la permission de tourner
pour la grande vadrouille dans l'Opéra
de Paris sur le toit de l'Opéra de Paris
dans dans la cour des Invalides pour les
aventures de Rabbi Jacob enfin des lieux
qui d'ailleurs donne une valeur
extraordinaire à la beauté à la grande
beauté au film donc c'est une c'est une
préoccupation qui a été très très
importante pour lui toujours de tenir
ses permissions en question quand on
parle cinéma on l'époque souvent la
réalisation des films rarement
l'élaboration d'un scénario alors que
tout part de là aux États-Unis
d'ailleurs les scénaristes sont souvent
plus reconnus est-ce qu'il y a une forme
d'ingratitude avec les scénaristes en
France d'ailleurs les scénaristes quand
ils se mettent en grève aux États-Unis
ça fait beaucoup parler ça paralyse le
cinéma je crois que nous d'abord je
pense que les scénaristes sont aussi
maltraités aux États-Unis qu'en France
je crois que il y a pas les envier mais
je crois qu'effectivement la grève va
être quelque chose de très grave et qui
d'ailleurs entraîne les comédiens parce
que maintenant les comédiens se mettent
en grève aussi mais je crois que le
problème sera le même en France si les
scénaristes se mettaient en grève parce
que tout repose sur nos épaules sur nos
cerveaux notre imaginaire notre
imagination et le voilà le talent en
France les scénaristes mais oui ils sont
mal traîner parce qu'ils sont mal payés
déjà ça c'est une forme de effectivement
de maltraitance et puis ils sont très
ils sont très ignorés personne connaît
leur nom personne c'est vraiment qui le
sont à part bien entendu à l'intérieur
du microcosme bien sûr le microcosme
professionnel et ça c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui est le plus important enfin on est
en effet si on a envie de de devenir un
peu célèbre il faut surtout pas être
scénariste mais si on a envie d'avoir un
métier magnifique il faut être
scénariste et j'ai envie de le creuser
ce métier pour comprendre comment un
scénario s'écrit je voudrais revenir sur
la façon dont ça a commencé pour vous
vous avez été très vite fasciné dès
votre plus jeune âge par la construction
d'un scénario et d'un film avec votre
père Gérard Oury vous dites j'étais rodé
à cette atmosphère étrange du bureau du
scénariste être dans une pièce pendant
des heures des semaines des mois par les
prendre des notes rire ne pas rire avoir
des moments de silence de panique se
demander si le film sera bien ou pas
bien c'est donc comme cela qu'un film
commence à partir de quelque chose c'est
comme ça que ça commence c'est comme ça
je pense que ça commence pour tout le
monde parce que je sais que quand je
parle à d'autres scénaristes ou que je
travaille d'ailleurs j'ai travaillé
évidemment avec beaucoup de de metteur
en scène quoi scénariste ou de cause
voilà c'est notre vie ça c'est notre vie
et je crois que la
principale qualité c'est l'acharnement
c'est la charnement autour d'une
histoire qu'on tient à raconter et que
par moment on se dit ce que vraiment ça
va ça va faire un film est-ce que
vraiment ça va être passionnant est-ce
que vraiment on va trouver ce qui va
venir après ce qui va se passer pour
pour séduire surprendre le spectateur
pour voilà pour créer une atmosphère
réadaptation accepté de changer dix fois
100 fois le scénario peut-être accepter
de de mettre la poubelle entre entre
guillemets puisque maintenant ça se
passe plus avec des papiers sauf chez
moi parce que j'écris toujours sur du
papier
mais intéressant mais c'est vrai que il
faut il faut il faut être très très
sévère avec soi-même et il faut un petit
peu un petit peu comme comme la levure
pour les pour le pain ou pour les
gâteaux il faut laisser reposer
et essayer d'avoir un œil neuf sur son
propre travail ce qui est une chose très
difficile et c'est pour ça qu'on l'a
souvent recours quand même à un
concertariste ou même des copains
auxquels on demande qu'est-ce que tu
penses où j'en suis qu'est-ce que je
fais parce qu'on est on est très perdus
après dans son propre travail votre père
avait une pochette verte dans laquelle
il glissait tout ce qui pouvait
l'inspirer en dessin un article la
retranscription d'un dialogue qui avait
pu le faire rire il l'a sorti au moment
d'écrire un nouveau scénario et vous
avez dit un jour pendant des années il y
avait cette feuille de papier sur
laquelle il avait marqué usine de
chewing-gum on avait jamais réussi à la
caser tout à coup cela nous a paru être
l'endroit idéal pour séquestrer Slimane
alors pour ceux qui l'ignoraient Slimane
c'est un personnage incroyable des
aventures de Rabbi Jacob et ça a donné
cette scène absolument dans l'usine de
chewing-gum est-ce que vous avez votre
pochette verte vous Daniel Thomson j'ai
toujours la pochette verte oui il y a
plus grand chose dedans parce qu'on a
beaucoup utilisé mais
c'est vrai que c'est d'ailleurs
anecdotique mais quand on a finalement
visité cette fameuse usine de
chewing-gum on est arrivé je me souviens
très bien je crois que c'était les
chewing-gum Hollywood on est arrivé dans
leur usine et là on a été désespéré
parce qu'en fait on s'est trouvé dans un
endroit complètement fermé avec des
immenses
comme des frigidaires géants nous a mis
des masques et des petits chapeaux sur
la tête enfin c'était absolument
surveillé
et il y avait pas du tout matière à
créer ces situations insensées qui
étaient évidemment imaginées dans le
scénario et donc on s'est rabattu sur
une usine de sucre et qui avec lesquels
on a raccordé évidemment un décor qui a
été ensuite construit en studio mais
cette visite de cette ville de
chewing-gum a été des moments les plus
douloureux possible parce qu'on s'est
dit mais on peut rien faire ici il y
avait pas évidemment
aucune grand moment
des illusions donc voilà on sait on se
rappelle vous avez au fond de vos
tiroirs et que vous avez envie de
ressortir un jour qui vous titille
oui oui il y en a il y a une ou deux
idées comme ça qui ont été des choses
que j'avais commencé à écrire et puis
qui se sont pas faites j'y pense
nous en parler non pas vraiment d'accord
non mais je pensais par exemple à Rabbi
Jacqueline donc vous avez parlé
plusieurs fois et puis qui devait être
une sorte de suite aux aventures de
Rabbi Jacob c'est définitivement terminé
c'est définitivement non c'est pas
définitivement terminé parce que en fait
ça a été ça a été une suite de tentative
exactement avec les séances de travail
dont vous venez de parler et avec tout à
coup en effet
embarquer dans un autre un autre
scénario qui était d'ailleurs ces années
moi puis ensuite dans la série Bardot
que qui vient de d'être diffusé et puis
mes scénaristes aussi partaient vers
d'autres projets donc on s'est un petit
peu essoufflé et puis l'actualité est
extrêmement
fluctuantes sans cesse et pas d'une
manière bien souriante il faut bien le
dire et cette actualité elle nous a
rattrapé tout le temps parce qu'en fait
les choses vont si vite et ce scénario
de Rabbi Jacqueline il doit contenir
quand même l'ADN du du premier film si
possible
c'est un film que j'adore et qui était
un petit peu touché par la grâce et qui
a enfin qui quand même
jouent sur des des thèmes qui sont en
effet le terrorisme la violence
le kidnapping et le conflit des
religions et l'incompréhension et le
racisme alors toutes ces toutes ces mots
que je viens de prononcer ils sont
toujours bien très très présents
aujourd'hui et dès qu'on avait une idée
bien le quelque chose nous rattrapait et
faisait que cette idée devenait très
très vite déjà déjà passé ou déjà trop
dans l'actualité ou pas assez mais c'est
l'A oui le problème c'est la frilosité
des diffuseurs des producteurs la
pression de l'opinion la pression des
réseaux sociaux est-ce que c'est pas ça
aussi qui qui freine le projet qui
l'empêche c'est surtout notre propre
notre propre conscience de tout à coup
aujourd'hui
de choses qu'on peut dire ou ne pas dire
de dialogue qu'on peut écrire ou pas
écrire de choses qui peuvent choquer ou
pas choquer il y a s'il y a
effectivement moins de de liberté de
légèreté
aujourd'hui qu'à l'époque de celle
qu'elles sont plus consensuelles
justement pour plaire un peu à tout le
monde est-ce que ça baisse la qualité
des comédies selon vous avec le regard
que vous avez en tout cas une comédie
comme effectivement Rabbi Jacqueline qui
serait qui serait en effet une moi le
thème étant de reprendre les personnages
qui sont les héritiers de de les
descendants de ces de ces personnages en
question donc musulmans catholique Juifs
etc qui se mélangent dans une aventure
qui doit être très drôle et en même
temps qui est quand même une aventure et
puis qui est une aventure un peu quand
même qui dans la violence donc on
l'oublie ça dans Rabbi Jacob mais enfin
c'est là et donc tout ça c'est très
compliqué parce que parce qu'il faut
faire attention aujourd'hui à ne pas
effectivement
avoir enfin ne pas se sentir qu'on est
un petit peu on bouscule certaines
choses et que les les choses aujourd'hui
sont beaucoup plus
cloisonné qu'elle ne l'était à l'époque
bien qu'à l'époque c'était pas facile
non plus l'actualité n'était pas simple
non plus mais mais voilà on avait on
avait on pouvait effectivement rire de
tout et là cette fameuse notion de rire
de tout je trouve qu'elle est en train
de se diminuer un petit peu le monde du
cinéma vous y êtes né vous y avez baigné
tout de suite donc je le disais fille de
Gérard Oury et de l'actrice Jacqueline
roman dès l'âge de 4 ans vous allez au
cinéma 3 à 4 fois par semaine à l'âge de
9 ans vous êtes frappé par un film en
particulier régulier miracle à Milan de
Vittorio De Sica est-ce que faire autre
chose qu'un métier lié au cinéma vous
était impossible est-ce qu'il y avait
quelque chose d'écrit non ça va oui et
non en fait je voulais être avocat j'ai
d'ailleurs fait un endroit
après mon bac et je me suis beaucoup
ennuyée
je pense que c'est une sorte de réaction
d'adolescence contre justement l'univers
de mes parents puis j'avais vu mais mon
père et ma mère beaucoup galéré s'il
était comédien quand j'étais enfant et
j'attendais les rendez-vous de casting
les contrats les preuves c'est un métier
qui était extrêmement extrêmement
fluctuant et très peu sécurisant et ça a
toujours été ça le reste bien sûr encore
aujourd'hui donc moi mon enfance elle a
été une enfance comme ça de roulotte de
tout à coup on avait assez d'argent pour
partir en vacances puis il y en avait
plus et puis et puis mes parents avaient
toujours des dettes et puis
enfin c'était c'était à la fois joyeux
et
finalement je pense que je me suis dit
bah moi je vais partir vers autre chose
et puis c'est vrai que je vais vous dire
aujourd'hui je pense que j'aurais pu
être une très bonne avocate mais parce
que j'aime la rhétorique parce que
j'aime le
j'aime les mots j'aime
je suis passionné par justement l'effet
divers qui vont qui vont profondément
chercher dans les raisons pour
lesquelles les gens font ne font pas des
choses mais alors à l'allure de celle
que vous êtes aujourd'hui quels conseils
donneriez-vous à la petite fille que
vous étiez que lui diriez-vous avant
qu'elle ne se lance dans la vie
qu'elle a eu qu'elle a eu raison de
changer d'avis
la collaboration avec votre père va se
faire très naturellement vous avez à
peine plus de 20 ans je crois vous
participez de manière un peu informelle
au scénario du corniaud qui va connaître
un immense succès et sur le film d'après
votre père vous embauche vraiment de
façon plus formelle plus officielle et
ce film c'est la Grande Vadrouille quand
votre père vous embauche est-ce que vous
avez dû en discuter depuis est-ce que
aussi avec la bienveillance d'un père
aimant ou est-ce qu'il avait repéré le
talent en vous c'était les deux c'était
les deux je pense que la plupart des
gens d'ailleurs pendant des années ont
dû penser que c'était seulement de la
bienveillance et du plaisir
effectivement de l'histoire à montrer
depuis que bien sûr mais bon ça je me
rendais compte de ça et puis je me suis
je crois assez bien débrouillé avec ça
parce que j'en ai pas fait
finalement un problème parce que je
pense que c'est ça qui peut beaucoup
coincer les fils de les filles de donc
je me suis dit bon je suis en train
d'apprendre un métier j'adore ça c'est
génial je je j'ai une chance folle
d'être embarquée dans une aventure
puisque effectivement la Grande
Vadrouille ça suivait le corniaud et
qu'on savait que le film se ferait qu'on
savait qu'on pouvait le faire avec les
moyens qu'on voulait et donc ça a été
une période d'apprentissage magnifique
avec mon père Marcel Julian qui était
notre notre scénariste donc
finalement les choses se sont emballées
comme ça et je pense que mais je pense
que mon père avait décelé chez moi
quelque chose qui qui lui apportait Dieu
portait en effet un autre point de vue
et puis et puis le fait que c'est très
intéressant ça je l'ai souvent dit et je
continue à le faire avec mon fils
puisque je travaille avec mon fils
le regard de quelqu'un d'une autre
génération et ça c'est très très
agréable et je pense que ça lui a
apporté beaucoup et ça m'a apporté
beaucoup moins avec mon fils
c'est en effet tout à coup une autre
manière de voir les choses et qui est
qui enrichissent énormément les
personnages d'un scénario je voudrais
vous montrer un document qui nous a été
remis par les Archives nationales qui
sont nos partenaires dans cette émission
c'est un document qui date du 28 octobre
1940 intitulé mesures prises contre les
Juifs il est écrit que la législation
française interdit désormais aux Juifs
d'entrer dans les grands corps de l'État
l'armée l'administration l'enseignement
la presse sauf scientifique et le
théâtre le cinéma et la radio le but
étant d'enlever aux Juifs je cite tout
influence politique militaire artistique
intellectuelle c'est précisément ce qui
va faire fuir votre père dont le vrai
nom était max Gérard
Oury Tannenbaum il était alors comédien
embauché par la Comédie Française et il
ne pouvait pas jouer et il fuit pour
échapper justement au nazis et à ce
genre de législation c'est pour ça que
vous connaissez à Monaco et oui c'est
pour ça je pense que je pense que
bizarrement cette cette fameuse ça
s'appelle mesure prise
je pense que je ne serai pas là
aujourd'hui si ce si finalement ce
document n'avait pas existé
enfin il aurait mieux valu qu'il
n'existe pas du tout mais comme il a
existé sa cité effectivement mon père et
ma mère donc il a embarqué sa fiancée
avec lui à l'époque et ils ont fui grâce
à ça parce qu'il travaillait à la
Comédie Française à la radio et que du
jour au lendemain on lui a dit Monsieur
Moury Tenenbaum puisque c'était le nom
du mari de sa mère toute une histoire la
famille il s'est appelé Tenenbaum d'où
son nom tout son enfance et ça et sa
maman Marcel Oury de toute façon était
juive donc c'était c'était réglé si
j'ose dire tu es foutu pour lui c'était
foutu ma mère elle-même avait un père
juif enfin bref tout ça le dernier
n'était pas très très facile à l'époque
et grâce à ça ils ont ils sont partis
ils sont partis en zone libre et c'est
là que je suis né en effet en 42 est-ce
qu'il est incroyable l'histoire est
vraiment atypique dès le début avec
votre père parce que votre naissance il
refuse de vous reconnaître
officiellement pour vous protéger des
nazis justement ils préfèrent que vous
preniez le nom de votre mère ben c'est à
dire que le le bizarrement d'ailleurs je
me suis toujours appelé Oury tout de
même je passe mais c'était pas légal
mais ma mère m'a effectivement déclaré à
la mairie de Monaco de père inconnue
et d'un stade comme un accord bien sûr
parce que alors les calculs sordides
épouvantables évidemment qui consistait
à dire que si on avait plus de deux
comme deux grands-parents Juifs on
pouvait être balancé dans le premier
train qui partait penser où et donc ils
ont prudemment décidé de me baptiser et
de et de ne déclarer de père inconnu et
après ça après des années de démarches
pour qu'il arrive à me reconnaître je
crois quand j'avais 16 ans comment
est-il réagi quand vous avez décidé de
devenir réalisatrice après avoir été
scénariste pendant de longues années il
a fait partie de ceux qui vous ont
encouragé
fêter film à toi beaucoup beaucoup
encouragé beaucoup mon père m'a beaucoup
m'encouragé l'homme de ma vie Albert
kowski m'a beaucoup encouragé mes
enfants les producteurs
tout le monde me disait fais ton film et
je me disais mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
tous c'est quoi mon film je suis
scénariste je me je me fond dans
l'univers de de beaucoup de mes dents en
scène merveilleux et différents je fais
des choses qui n'ont rien à voir les
unes avec les autres ce qui est génial
pour un scénariste et puis la curiosité
l'emportait le fait que j'étais déjà
plus si jeune que ça et je me disais oh
là là si je commence pas si j'essaye pas
si j'ai un essai en fait c'est vraiment
un essai et puis comme les l'essai s'est
bien passé puisque c'était la bûche ça a
été réussie 99 la bûche qui fait un
carton quatre nominations au César
notamment pour la première oeuvre de
fiction la meilleure oeuvre de fiction
Charlotte Gainsbourg obtient le César de
la meilleure actrice dans un second rôle
et c'est là que vous dites vous
découvrez le bonheur de diriger des
acteurs ce qui naïvement peut paraître
un peu surprenant parce qu'on se dit que
ça peut être un peu compliqué de diriger
des acteurs d'ailleurs votre père disait
lui-même un acteur c'est comme du papier
de soie si on le froid c'est fichu ils
sont un peu à fleur de peau ces acteurs
ça doit pas être simple quand même de
les diriger
ça a été finalement tout de suite simple
c'est ça qui m'a complètement surprise
moi-même parce que j'ai adoré ce contact
avec eux j'ai déjà adoré justement
arrivé à déceler un petit peu vous savez
ils sont très différents les uns des
autres
certaines qu'on leur donne des
indications d'autres pas il faut arriver
à trouver cette cette équilibre avec
chacun et puis je me suis surtout aperçu
que ça a été un grand bonheur que
j'avais pas eu avant et effectivement
comme de toute façon j'écrivais les
dialogues
ne me retrouver directement avec cette
cette direction d'acteurs que moi j'aime
un mot que j'aime beaucoup pour
justement les orienter ou pas d'ailleurs
parce qu'il faut les laisser aussi
l'interpréter l'interprétation donc il
faut mais après bon d'avoir cette cette
main mise si j'ose dire sur la manière
dont mes dialogues vont être traités
alors que d'habitude ben c'était le
metteur en scène qui faisait cette
démarche intermédiaire et puis de temps
en temps on pouvait surpris en bien ou
en mal parce que c'était mieux qu'on
avait prévu ou moins bien et là j'ai
vraiment adoré ce travail et puis j'ai
je pense que si ça vient de justement de
mon enfance dont je parlais tout à
l'heure j'ai quand même été élevé par
deux comédiens et je connais leur ville
leurs angoisses de l'Intérieur donc j'ai
adoré ça et puis il y a cette incursion
dans un cinéma pas du tout comique à
l'opposé de ce que vous faisiez avant la
reine Margaux
1994 à partir d'une collaboration avec
Patrice Chereau mettant en scène de
théâtre mélange des gens entre lui et
vous le cinéma d'auteur le théâtre
public est subventionné d'un côté puis
le cinéma grand public de l'autre c'est
vous qui lui avait soufflé l'idée je
crois de la Reine Margot vous aviez
envie de vous confronter un autre
registre un autre genre
j'avais envie comme je le disais tout à
l'heure
ce qui est merveilleux dans ce métier de
scénariste c'est que justement on peut
partir un peu partout dans des domaines
très très différents donc quand en effet
Patrice Géraud qui est qui était un ami
à nous Albert et moi
m'a contacté parce qu'il était en train
de travailler sur un projet qui était en
fait les trois mousquetaires c'est drôle
puisque c'est mérite fait refaire refait
ça a été fait mille fois donc ce projet
ne se faisait pas il était très très
désolé parce qu'il avait beaucoup
beaucoup travaillé là-dessus et pour les
élèves de son école donc
on a vu les amandiers bien sûr
et là il m'a dit est-ce que tu as une
autre est-ce que tu aurais une idée
effectivement j'avais une idée parce que
j'avais lu et relu cette série de romans
trilogie la Reine Margot et la Dame de
Monsoreau et les 45 qui est l'histoire
de la fin des Valois je lui apportais ce
roman et je savais qu'il avait aussi
lui-même au théâtre mis en scène
massacre à Paris cette pièce de Marlow
qui était autour autour de la
Saint-Barthélémy et donc je savais que
c'était aussi une période qu'il
passionnait et donc c'est parti comme ça
et moi surtout j'avais fait ça
amicalement et je ne savais pas du tout
si il avait l'intention de demander de
travailler avec lui parce que c'était
très bizarre le grand saut de la boum à
la reine Margaux deux univers
complètement posés et d'ailleurs tous
ces amis à lui tu es un peu horrifié par
cette idée de que de travailler avec lui
je crois et et puis en revanche mes
copains moi me disait merde tu vas
travailler avec Jérôme on était très
ébloui mais lui a fait ce choix il l'a
su il a fait ce choix il a assumé je
crois qu'il a pas regretté et je crois
que ce choix était aussi intéressant
pour que l'autre béry notre producteur
parce que parce que Claude voulait faire
un grand film populaire en fait la Reine
Margot a été à mi-chemin entre un grand
film populaire et l'univers de Patrice
qui est qui est un petit peu plus disons
intellectuel plus vous avez écrit et
réalisé pour la télévision avec Bardot
une série de 6 épisodes écrites et
réalisés par Christopher Thompson et
vous-même donc Christopher Thomson on
l'aura compris votre fils
œuvre qui raconte la vie de Brigitte
Bardot entre 1949 et 1960 une femme
scandaleuse une femme qui va faire
éclater sa liberté à la figure d'une
époque très conservatrice finalement
l'écriture de série c'est quelque chose
c'est la tendance des dernières années
mais c'est quand même j'imagine très
différent de l'écriture que vous avez
pratiqué pendant des dizaines d'années
on s'y fait facilement à cette écriture
de série de mini série comme on dit
aujourd'hui alors moi j'ai commencé très
tôt j'ai commencé à écrire pour la
télévision dans les années 70 et j'ai
toujours écrit pour la télévision
j'avais écrit une fameuse sérieuse parce
que beaucoup elle est venue un peu
cultes qui s'appelait petit déjeuner
compris
mise en scène par Michel Berny et qui
était qui a été un énorme succès on
avait trois chaînes à l'époque on
faisait 72 73% d'audience ça fait rêver
et donc j'ai toujours écrit pour la
télévision et et donc ça n'a pas été
nouveau pour moi ce qui a été nouveau
c'est la mise en scène à la télévision
ça c'est la première fois et c'est un
peu tard mais je m'y mets et alors ça
donne quoi c'est j'ai adoré ça j'ai
adoré ce rythme j'ai j'avais très peur
de de la fatigue de effectivement de
d'être un peu bousculé dans
le rythme dans le par le rythme et il se
rythme m'a bien plu ce rythme ne m'a pas
plus fatigué que que que de faire un
film j'ai en plus été vraiment une
expérience très passionnante et très
merveilleuse de travailler avec mon fils
donc on avait partagé chacun chacun
certains épisodes et qui sont donc
aujourd'hui toujours sur France
point télé et donc
je je me suis sentie bien sur ce sur ce
plateau avec ça avec ce effectivement ce
rythme de beaucoup beaucoup de minutes
par jour
j'ai des photos à vous proposer Daniel
Thompson il s'agit de destrie à
l'inspielberg elle est la fille de
Steven Spielberg très grand réalisateur
qu'on ne présente pas et de Kate cap
chaud elle a décidé de se lancer comme
réalisatrice à son tour son père se dit
très fier d'elle dans votre famille on
est réalisateur de parents en enfant
quels conseils donneriez-vous à la fille
Spielberg qui se lance
[Rires]
et de et de beaucoup travailler et de et
de se débarrasser de tout ce que de tout
ce que peuvent penser les autres
c'est une jeune femme qui pose qui prend
la pose devant l'entrée du camp
d'Auschwitz c'est la grande mode des
selfies aussi sur ce lieu terrible un
phénomène qui prend une telle ampleur
que le mémorial d'Auschwitz a fait un
rappel à l'ordre visiteur comment la
fille d'un homme qui a fui les mesures
anti juifs pendant la guerre
perçoit-elle cela est-ce que j'ai vu
cette photo
vous savez c'est le mauvais goût ambiant
en même temps je trouve que c'est
important que le plus de monde possible
Vienne visiter ce lieu et se souvienne
bien sûr encore une fois ambiguïté et
maintenant le mauvais goût il est il est
malheureusement transcendé par les
réseaux sociaux
et donc tout le monde voit cette photo
et et
bon bah c'est c'est très très mauvais
goût
mais l'air d'une narcissique voilà c'est
moins grave que ce qui s'est vraiment
passé là-bas une dernière question qui
est en lien avec notre lieu Daniel
Thompson nous sommes entourés de quatre
statues qui représentent chacune une
vertu il y a ici la sagesse ici la
prudence ici la justice et derrière moi
l'éloquence laquelle de ces statues de
ses vertus vous caractérise le plus ou à
laquelle vous auriez envie de vous
référer
je pense la sagesse la sagesse
pourquoi parce que c'est un art de vivre
c'est un art de c'est un
art de finalement d'avoir le sens des
proportions dans la vie des priorités
et je crois que ça ça guide beaucoup
beaucoup de de ma vie en tous les cas et
donc voilà et de se rendre compte de la
chance qu'on a quand on en a et puis de
ne pas attacher trop d'importance aux
choses qui n'en ont pas et d'adapter et
d'avoir de donner beaucoup d'importance
aux choses qui en ont la sagesse on
s'arrêtera sur ce mot merci infiniment
Daniel d'avoir été avec nous dans ce
rendez-vous si je lis merci merci
beaucoup et merci à vous de nous avoir
suivis comme chaque semaine à très vite
sur Public Sénat merci
[Musique]